PROFESSOR: The cost
of a numerical method
for solving ordinary
differential equations is
measured by the number of times
it evaluates the function f
per step.
Euler's method evaluates
f once per step.
Here's a new method that
evaluates it twice per step.
If f is evaluated once at
the beginning of the step
to give a slope
s1, and then s1 is
used to take Euler's step
halfway across the interval,
the function is evaluated in
the middle of the interval
to give the slope s2.
And then s2 is used
to take the step.
For obvious reasons, this is
called the midpoint method.
Here's ode2.
It implements the
midpoint method,
evaluates the function
twice per step.
The structure is
the same as ode1.
Same arguments, same
for loop, but now we
have s1 at the beginning
of the step, s2
in the middle of the
step, and then the step
is actually taken with s2.
Here's an example
involving a trig function.
Dy dt is the square root
of 1, minus y squared.
Starting at the origin on the
interval from 0 to pi over 2.
Now, because I've called
it a trig example,
you might just-- this is
a separable equation--
do the integral, or you can
just guess at the-- guess
that the answer is sine t.
Because the derivative of
sine t is the cosine of t,
and that's the square
root of 1 minus y squared.
Let's set it up.
F is the anonymous
function square
root of 1 minus y squared.
T0 is 0.
I'm going to take
h to be pi over 32.
And tfinal is pi over 2.
And y0 is 0.
And here's my call to ode2,
with these five arguments,
and it produces this output.
Now I want to plot it.
Let's get t to go along with it.
There is the t
values as a column--
vector-- and let's plot.
And do some annotation
on the plot.
Here's our plot.
So there's the graph of our,
there's the graph of sine t,
the points generated by ode2.
Now I can't help but go
look at these answers.
This is supposed to be
the values of sine t.
This should be getting
to 1 at pi over 2.
We've got 0.997.
That gives you a rough idea
of what kind of accuracy
we're getting out of this
crude numerical method.
Let's take a look
at an animation
of the midpoint method.
The differential equation is
y prime is 2y, starting at t0
equals 0 with a step
size of 1, going up to 3,
and starting with y0
equals 10, and using ode2.
Here is the animation.
Here's t0 and y0.
Evaluate the function at y0.
2 times y0 is 20, step
halfway across the interval
with that slope,
that gets us to 20.
Evaluate the function
there, the slope
is 40, so we take a
step with slope 40
all the way across the
interval to get up to 50.
That's the first step.
Now we'll rescale
the plot window.
Here we are at 50.
Evaluate the function there.
The slope is 100, step
halfway with that slope,
get to the middle
of the interval,
evaluate the function there.
The slope is 200, so we
take a step with slope 200
to get up to 250.
That's the second step.
Rescale the plot window.
Evaluate the function there.
The slope is 500.
Take that step halfway
across the interval,
evaluate the slope there.
The slope is 1,000, so we take
a step with slope of 1,000
to get up to 1,250
as our final value.
Since this is a rapidly
increasing function of y,
the values we generate here
with the midpoint method
are far larger than the values
generated with the Euler method
that we saw with ode1.
Here's an exercise.
Modify ode2, creating ode2t,
which implements the companion
method, the trapezoid method.
Evaluate the function
at the beginning
of the interval to get s1.
Use s1 to go all the
way across the interval.
Evaluate the function at
the right-hand endpoint
of the interval to get s2.
And then, use the average of
s1 and s2 to take the step.
That's the trapezoid method.